si sabemos que la recta am tiene esta
ecuación la red también contiene al
punto 67 y la recta am y la recta ven
son perpendiculares
este dato creo que va a ser muy
importante que son perpendiculares
entonces cuál es la ecuación de la recta
b y bueno lo primero que quiero que
recordemos es que significa que la recta
am y la recta ven sean perpendiculares
bueno la recta y la recta ven son
perpendiculares si la pendiente de la
recta b es el inverso multiplicativo
negativo el inverso
un verso multiplicativo multiplicativo
negativo de la pendiente de a es decir
que la pendiente de b es el inverso
multiplicativo negativo de la pendiente
de a de la pendiente de a esto también
lo podemos ver la siguiente manera que
la pendiente debe por la pendiente de a
esto sea igual a menos 1 estas dos
formas son equivalentes es lo mismo
decir que es el inverso multiplicativo
de la pendiente de am o que la
multiplicación de estas dos pendientes
sea igual a menos 1 y bueno yo sé que la
recta am tiene esta ecuación entonces si
la recta aquí en esta ecuación su
pendiente es el valor que está al lado
de la x es decir 2
esta es la pendiente de la recta a y la
voy a ocupar porque si yace la pendiente
de la recta am la pendiente de la recta
b tiene que ser el inverso
multiplicativo de la pendiente de la
recta a entonces
pendiente de la recta de la pendiente
diente debe como tiene que ser bueno la
pendiente de bem tiene que ser igual a
quien a la pendiente de la recta pero
tiene que ser el inverso multiplicativo
entonces el inverso multiplicativo de 2
es un medio pero además tiene que ser
negativo por lo tanto tiene que ser
menos un medio con signo contrario una
tiene que quedar con signo positivo y la
otra con signo negativo ya tengo la
pendiente de la recta bien por lo tanto
vamos a decir que la recta b tiene como
ecuación bien es igual a m
pero la pendiente ya sé que tiene que
ser igual a menos un medio a menos un
medio por x más b ahora lo que me falta
determinar es cuánto vale bien ahora lo
que quiero saber es cuánto vale
pero para sacar a ver voy a utilizar el
doctor dato que me dan la recta con
tiende al punto 67 es decir que este
punto como está en mi recta me cumplen
esta ecuación o dicho de otra manera
cuando equivale a 6 lleva al menos 7 en
esta ecuación entonces sustituyendo este
punto que me va a quedar 10 vale menos 7
entonces menos 7 esto tiene que ser
igual a menos un medio
déjame cambiar de color a menos un medio
por equis pero x en este punto vale 6
entonces a esto vamos a multiplicar por
6 más ven a esto lo voy a multiplicar
por 6 ya esto le tenemos que sumar b
entonces a esto le voy a sumar ven y así
voy a obtener el valor de v lo único que
tengo que hacer es despejar a ver me
queda que menos 7 esto tiene que ser
igual a menos un medio por 6 esto es
menos 3
y de aquí si sumo tres de ambos lados de
la ecuación me va a quedar que es igual
a menos 73 lo cual es menos 4 esto es
igual a menos 4 entonces ya sé el valor
de vemos el valor de bem es igual a
menos 4 y entonces ya puedo escribir de
una manera ordenada la ecuación de la
recta b
la recta b tiene como ecuación a la
expresión james esto es igual a la
pendiente pero la pendiente es igual a
menos un medio recuerda que este menos
un medio salió como el inverso
multiplicativo negativo de 2 esto hay
que multiplicarlo por equis y le voy a
sumar b pero vale menos 4 y por lo tanto
lo hemos logrado esto de aquí ya es mi
respuesta y por lo tanto no hay más que
hacer nos vemos en el siguiente vídeo